[Music]
I think that we've seen an unprecedented
salt on Armenia we've seen an a deep
villain ization of our free press this
and in fact a war on objectively true
information that when something is
reported that someone does not like you
can just say it's not true whether it is
or not you can try to undercut the
messenger and talk about how these are
just biased reporters don't listen to
them when in fact often these are fair
reporters who worked very hard to get
things right that has real ramifications
I mean we're facing the prospect of
living in a world that is post truth
where there are no objective troops
where where you can tell me the sky is
purple or sky is green when in fact
we're looking at it we see that it's
blue that becomes very dangerous
potentially for democracy right because
in a world in which the truth is
unknowable how do we make governing
decisions and then also how do we hold
people accountable how do we demand
better of our elected officials if our
elect officials do not have to deny who
do not have to acknowledge reality at
any point in time right they can just
tell us that no they did not say the
thing they said no this policy would not
do the things we know it would do I
think that's particularly dangerous and
I think that it's difficult I mean I
don't think that there's any coincidence
and the fact that our press freedoms are
one of the first things that our
founders enshrined in our Constitution I
think there's a reason for that because
what they saw through their own
experiences with their ability to tell
the truth their ability whether it be
through the penny press or 0 through
spoken word what was what sparked their
revolution and they knew that
safeguarding that that potential in
those outlets were what would but one
day give the United States of America
the capacity to deal with an existential
threat and I think that that's what we
face now is is the potential of having
our press so undermined then it can no
longer be a safeguard of our democracy
and we've seen this right we see then we
seen this going back several years this
idea that somehow the media must be held
accountable instead of the elected
officials being held accountable we saw
was in Ferguson we saw
because we love as a society as a
culture to attack messengers when the
message is something that makes us feel
uncomfortable so reporters who reported
on things like police shootings and race
and justice became the targets because
if only you could discredit them if you
could prove they had some vendetta or
some bias that they were they were
really just some liberal operative then
you didn't have to engage at all with
what they were saying and so what we've
seen is reporters being attacked
personally whether it be through threats
whether it be through their address is
being published whether it be through
smear campaigns trying to undermine
things people not approaching their work
or their correspondences in good faith
and again I think this is particularly
dangerous because it allows this
undermining of the norm of journalists
by and large being good people trying to
do good work who get it right more often
they get it wrong and that is the
reality but when the public stops
believing that it's the reality it
raises real questions about our ability
to do our job
[Music]